[Music]
hello everyone
at the end of the previous lecture we
had briefly
discuss the connection between the
potential energy
and elastic systems and in this lecture
we are going to elaborate on that point
so a mechanical system more specifically
the material making up a
mechanical system is said to be elastic
if the internal forces
uh are conservative in the kinetic sense
okay so we mentioned this here
it's said to be elastic if
the internal forces
are conservative in the kinetic sense
okay
now we had also discussed in the
previous lecture that
if we do have uh external forces or
internal forces to be conservative
then there would be a point function
called the potential energy
associated with such kind of external
forces on internal forces
now for these elastic systems since we
are seeing that the internal forces are
conservative
specifically in the kinetic sense but
but since they are conservative
there must be a point function
called the potential energy associated
with these
internal forces okay so
we have such a thing the vi which is the
potential energy
associated with these conservative
internal forces
now earlier in one of the earlier
lectures
we had mentioned that
after discussing a point about the
internal energy we had gone on to
to re-express an expression uh
or to re uh to rewrite an expression uh
involving the
internal energy in terms of the internal
energy density
so in a similar fashion we can also have
ah
a density kind of a potential energy
associated with this
but uh what we need to mention before
that is
uh for this particular kind of system uh
where
we have the internal forces are
conservative in the kinetic sense
uh making the system to be elastic this
particular kind of potential energy
associated with the internal forces
that is referred that itself is referred
to as the strain energy
okay so this itself this entire thing
itself is
called the strain energy
okay so what we are going to say is that
we can define a strain energy density
bi not
such that we have
p i is equal to
and again you must be careful to to
distinguish between this v
and this v this v is the volume this way
is the volume
and this v of course is uh is the one
associated with the
strain energy density
okay now
uh a very very important point to note
uh and especially for this elastic
systems is that
uh this strain energy density okay
the strain energy density
will be a function
of the various strain components
please note that uh
ever since we had our
previous lecture on the principle of
virtual work
applied to deformable body we have been
narrowing down our of our entire
discussions associated with
deformable bodies only in such kind of
deformable bodies we can have strain
components
and what we are saying right now is that
this strain energy density
will be a function of the of the
strained components
now this is is a rather
a large claim and we can have a
very very elaborate discussion
associated with this but that kind of a
discussion would be more suitable
uh in a full-fledged course on
continuous mechanics and thermodynamics
not in this particular kind of course so
we will
will not go into the deep details of it
uh
people who are interested in such
questions may refer to a book on
continuous mechanics and
uh but for now we'll just stop here okay
uh
regarding this point so we'll be just
saying that the strain energy density
v i naught is
basically the i naught as a function
of epsilon i j
now if you accept this then uh
the first variation of this
v i naught that can be written
as
so please note that when i write this
statement i am not
carrying out anything which requires uh
knowledge of the mechanics of the system
this is purely following
from the from our mathematical uh
knowledge
so uh i mean written in this fashion
it may seem a little bit alien but
perhaps you can draw an analogy
uh to understand this with uh what you
used to do
in engineering mathematics for the
differentials
okay so there also we had if we had a
certain variable to be dependent on a
number of
entities then the differential of that
thing could be written as
uh this kind of term so for example if
you had uh
for example if so hypothetically saying
that if we are considering an ordinary
differential of this
uh of a of a variable like v here and
suppose
that we were to be dependent not just on
the strain components but also
let's say on the temperature and many
other entities then we would have a
partial derivative with respect to the
strains like this and multiplied by the
differential
of the strain plus we'll have
a partial derivative of this vi
with respect to the temperature then a
different multiplied by the ordinary
uh ordinary differential of the
temperature plus similar other terms
but we have here only as a simple
dependence
on one entity which is why we have only
one quantity
like this okay there is nothing more to
it
now uh all this is that that we have
been discussing here this has been
following from
uh our our considerations of potential
energy which we started
uh in our discussion of which we started
in our
previous lecture now the question is how
can we connect this
to our earlier discussions uh regarding
the virtual work
and so on okay so here is a crucial
juncture
in our discussion and the connecting
link between this discussion and that
earlier discussion involving the
work done uh the virtual work done
that will be established through the uh
through the understanding that uh
for uh the
the strain energy of the system it
basically differs from the internal
energy
only by an additive constant so this is
a very very important statement
so let me write that down
note that the
the strain energy of the system
differs from the internal energy
only by an additive constant
and because we will be
mostly interested in tracking changes of
this internal energy
therefore this additive constant is
basically
going to be irrelevant
so for all intents and purposes what we
can say is
that delta vi
is going to be basically equivalent to
delta so delta vi naught
is basically going to be equivalent to
delta u y naught
okay this is very very important to note
and this happens only because of the
presence of this additive constant
uh we should not fall under the wrong
impression that the
the strain energy density is absolutely
equal to the internal energy
density that is not so there is an
additive constant difference but when we
consider changes in these things so then
they become
equal so what we can say is that
because we had we had just
previously in the previous slide we had
obtained that delta v i naught
is equal to del v i naught
del epsilon i j
delta epsilon i j so this directly gives
us
that
delta u y naught is also equal to
del u y naught l epsilon i j
delta epsilon i j okay
now uh
uh in a in an earlier lecture what we
had
obtained okay so this so as i told you
we wish to make
a connection with our earlier uh with
our discussions in our earlier classes
so in one of those earlier classes we
had actually obtained this expression
so earlier we had found
that the first variation of the the
external work done
that is equal to
integration of the first variation of
the internal energy
over the entire volume okay so
now what we'll do is we will
reconsider this expression back when we
had derived this
we had been uh we had been interested
in the so basically you remember that we
we discussed this in the context of our
discussion of
first law of thermodynamics and we went
on to say that this would be true
under the conditions that that the
process we are interested
in are adiabatic as well as
the the systems are in static in static
equilibrium so that the changes in
kinetic energy are 0. so the external
work done
the first variation of that is equal to
the this thing
now in view of what we have just
described
regarding the equivalence of the
the first variation of the strain energy
density and the first variation
of the internal energy density uh
sorry i made a little mistake in the
notation
with this thing it will be simply u
naught okay there is no u i not
it's just u naught similarly here this
is simply going to be
u naught sorry about that
okay so that u naught is the same as
this u naught but now we are going to
reinterpret the meaning of this
expression
to say that the first variation of the
external work done
that is equal to the integration of the
first variation of the strain energy so
we understand this thing
to be the first variation of the strain
energy okay
so now and this is what is
going to enable us to to make the
connection
with what we had just written in terms
of the strains
all right so from this we can
write that
del u naught del
epsilon i j delta epsilon i j
basically we are just using this but
understanding that
this is basically falling from this
strain energy concept
db now uh
remember that
we had also obtained uh from
uh from the lecture where we were
discussing about the principle of
virtual work
applied to a deformable body the
relation
that
that let me just write it here
again earlier we had found
earlier we had found that
this expression okay so you can refer
back to
the the lecture on the principle of
virtual work
applied to deformable body so
now you make a comparison between this
expression here
and this expression the left hand side
is this first variation of
the external work is the first variation
of the external work
on the right hand side we have a volume
integral on the right hand side we have
a volume integral
we have this term delta epsilon i j here
we have the delta epsilon i j here
the only difference is that we have del
u naught
del epsilon i j and here we have sigma i
j
so if you compare
this equation
with this equation
so
we obtain the all important relation
that sigma i j is equal to
del u naught
del epsilon i j
so you many of you are already familiar
with this
uh this relation may be in different
forms from your undergraduate studies
so what this is basically telling us is
that if we
if we know the the strain energy because
mind you that we are
we are working under the under this uh
this equivalence okay where this u
naught is basically representing
the uh the strain energy density so if
you know the strain energy density
so from that uh so if you know the
strain energy density of course in terms
of the strain components then
from that expression through this
partial derivatives
we can obtain the sigma ij so this has a
direct connection
with the way we set up our constitutive
equations
of course such a discussion in on a more
rigorous
form can be possible only through
a a step-by-step development
as it is done in a continuum mechanics
course we do not have the luxury of time
and certainly not the scope of
we do not have the time to delve into
that and and the scope of this course
also does not allow that
but it is very much possible so within
the limited scope that we have here in
the limited time
uh we have managed to somehow show that
that we
it is it is possible to arrive at this
all-important
relation okay so this is a very very
important relation so this is the prime
thing that we obtained
uh from the from our discussion of the
strain energy
uh topic now directly
uh connected with this discussion
uh is the question okay so we have
obtained the sigma ij
in terms of this derivative with respect
to the epsilon i j
now one can very well question from this
that is it perhaps possible to obtain
the counterpart of this that is it
perhaps possible
okay is it perhaps possible
to obtain a relation where we have
something like this
okay of course we do not know what this
is so we
we just put a blank space here okay
so again there is a question mark here
first of all
is it possible to find out such an
expression
and can we obtain this kind of
a uh an equality for the epsilon i j in
terms of this derivative with respect to
sigma i j
so this is a a motivating question
for our next topic of discussion which
is the complementary energy
all right so on that note i will end
this lecture thank you very much